un spectacle d'andré en direction est
égal de michel brand réalisation de
jacques et la voici la descriptible
enthousiates exceptionnel l'admirable
réduisant le super bien matin
merci merci
vous voulez que je vous montre le dos
c'est pareil regarder ça c'est non ça se
fait au maître ça c'est joli c'est un
lent mais puis alors comme on dit que le
ver ci est au rouquin moi j'ai voulu
mettre au vert et je me suis fait aucun
pour l'occasion rassurez vous c'est une
perruque car j'aimais beaucoup d'autres
dites moi dites moi vous savez que dans
mon courrier
on me demande très souvent on me le
vendre et souvent le droit qu'est devenu
votre chenilles blum la chenille ah oui
plum la chenille ploum ploum et bien
elle a beaucoup d' aventure mais mais je
crois qu'il faudrait revenir un peu en
arrière vous savez que plume à une
petite famille
et justement c'est une petite histoire
vous savez que plume en fait a fait
beaucoup de spectacles un ronnie wood
cette chenille française a fait des
ravages à hollywood et elle a fait la
rencontre d'un petit million français
charmant d'ailleurs tout rouge comme à
perruque mais elle a voulu retrouver
paris et son atmosphère la java et/ou
septembre et je vous en remercie
beaucoup
voici plum la chenille
hu
voilà la banque verte
ensuite le maire aussi bien
ou tu es robison c'est soit 10 mois
tu verrais est ce que tu veux bon
aujourd'hui ses copines nombreuses
nous pensons mais nous la joue droite
attention nous voilà la jab à la fin du
mois entre la maison les petits nous
attendent au wip et si on les petits de
t'attendre vite fait
hu et ben moi je alors où la houle au
rouleau le rouleau s'émerveiller on
c'est extraordinaire c'est magnifique
suivez les petits suivez votre chère
petite maman faillite voilà c'est fini
au revoir à bientôt